hätte er heute live schön dass ihr dabei
seid ihr drei wochen ist die
flutkatastrophe im westen deutschlands
nun her und besonders schlimm getroffen
hat es dem kreis ahrweiler in rheinland
pfalz gibt es stand heute 141
todesopfern
16 menschen wurden verletzt über 700
wurden verletzt und 16 menschen werden
noch vermisst so rum ist es richtig ja
so viele menschen haben ihr zuhause
verloren stehen vor dem nichts
tagtäglich während die helferinnen jeden
tag und die helfer versuchen beim
wiederaufbau zu helfen steht über allem
die frage hätte diese katastrophe
verhindert werden können und wurde zu
spät gewarnt dazu gibt es heute eine
pressekonferenz der staatsanwaltschaft
koblenz gesehen was denn gegen den
landkreis den landrat des kreises
ahrweiler wird ermittelt wir schauen
jetzt mal ein
ja offensichtlich haben wir noch einen
moment zu sprechen
das wollen wir nutzen die zeit mit
politikern aus unserem zdf-studio
rheinland pfalz wo du hast diese
katastrophe von anfang an scharf fällt
und welche vorwürfe gegen den landrat
geht es da genau
also das ist am 14 juli bis 14
juli große unwetter geben sollten sehr
herzlich und dieser stelle erst mal den
hausherren hier der sich bescheiden in
den hintergrund gesetzt hat den
polizeipräsidenten dass wir diesen raum
und auch die logistik hier benutzen
dürfen
der anlass für diese pressekonferenz ist
ein zutiefst traurig 141 menschen sind
mit stand heute bei der schrecklichen
unwetterkatastrophe am 14 und 15 7 2021
im aartal getötet worden mehr als 700
menschen abend teils schwere
verletzungen erlitten
und natürlich hat es auch große schäden
an privatem und öffentlichem eigentum
sowie der infrastruktur gegeben
der täter von alledem ist in erster
linie die nach schicksal so hat es ein
kriminalbeamter formuliert und das
stimmt sicherlich und das sollte bei
alledem was ich ihnen gleich vortragen
werde nicht vergessen werden
gleichwohl kann man auch in einem
solchen fall strafrechtlich relevantes
menschliches verhalten möglicherweise
finden das zum tod und zur verletzung
dieser menschen beigetragen hat ob es
hierfür einen anfangsverdacht gibt haben
wir bei der staatsanwaltschaft koblenz
über längere zeit hinweg geprüft und
nunmehr wie sie schon heute vormittag
erfahren haben ein ermittlungsverfahren
gegen zwei beschuldigte eingeleitet
bevor ich darauf im einzelnen eingehen
möchte ich uns jedoch kurz vorstellen
zu meiner linken wenn ich dann mal
wieder platz genommen habe sitzt der
präsident des landeskriminalamtes
rheinland pfalz herr johannes kunz und
zu meiner rechten die dezernenten des
staatsanwaltschaftlichen verfahrens die
oberstaatsanwältin adam backen
mein name ist bereitet die
staatsanwaltschaft hier in koblenz aber
nun zur sache
unsere heutigen presseerklärung haben
sie entnommen dass wir bereits
vorgestern ein ermittlungsverfahren
eingeleitet haben dass sich gegen zwei
personen wegen des verdachts der
fahrlässigen tötung und der fahrlässigen
körperverletzung gegebenenfalls im amt
und begangen durch unterlassen richtet
ich möchte ihnen kurz zunächst erläutern
wie unsere prüfung des anfangsverdachts
abgelaufen ist
in einem weiteren abschnitt werde ich
ihnen dann die bewertungen vorstellen zu
denen wir gekommen sind und zuletzt
möchte ich auch darlegen worauf die
weiteren ermittlungen vorrangig nach dem
derzeitigen stand zu richten sein werden
sollen die lage im aartal war in den
ersten tagen nach der katastrophe aus
unserer sicht zunächst sehr
unübersichtlich das galt insbesondere
auch für die frage ob es womöglich
fehler bei alarmierungen oder ähnlichem
gegeben hat so auf fehlende oder zu spät
und auch unzureichende war
den verlauf der a bis zu ihrer mit man
kripp durchlaufen hatte beide eindrücke
waren nach vorläufiger bewertung heute
nicht richtig doch dazu komme ich gleich
später es ergaben sich dann nach einiger
zeit erste zweifel an diesem eindruck es
habe sich bei dieser flutkatastrophe um
ein nicht abwendbar receive saal
gehandelt spätestens zur mitte der
vergangenen woche verdichteten sich
hinweise darauf dass es im alarmierungs
verhalten durch den krisenstab der
kreisverwaltung ahrweiler lücken gibt
die der landkreis jedenfalls öffentlich
nicht begründet hat wir haben das zum
anlass genommen eine sorgfältige
auswertung der gesamten zu dem zeitpunkt
bei uns dokumenten dokumentierten
medienberichterstattung durchzuführen
die dann im ergebnis den befund solcher
lücken bestätigt hat und die
insbesondere auch gezeigt hat dass man
aus den vielen mosaiksteinchen die über
die tage in den unterschiedlichen
artikeln und beiträgen genannt worden
waren
ein doch vergleichsweise wenig
widersprüchliches bild zeichnen konnte
hiervon ausgehend haben wir dann
versucht aus weiteren quellen
informationen zusammenzutragen
so sind die bei der staatsanwaltschaft
koblenz anhängig geworden denn
todesermittlungsverfahren daraufhin
gesichtet worden wie sich die todesfälle
entlang der ahr verteilen
außerdem konnten polizeiliche
erkenntnisse zum ablauf der tragödie im
haus der lebenshilfe in sinzig mit
einbezogen werden
und nicht zuletzt haben wir auch die
insbesondere in dieser woche seit montag
eingegangenen etwa 60 bis 70 hinweise
aus der bevölkerung bei unseren
überlegungen berücksichtigen können für
diese hinweise möchte ich mich an dieser
stelle ganz besonders herzlich bedanken
viele menschen haben uns ihre teils
wirklich erschütternden erlebnisse mit
dem hochwasser geschildert
andere haben uns aus ihrer beruflichen
expertise oder ihre expertise als
katastrophenschützer heraus wertvolle
tipps gegeben die wir im verlauf der
ermittlungen sicherlich berücksichtigen
werden
das mail-postfach dass wir an
eingerichtet haben und das auch auf die
hochwasser seite des landes
rheinland-pfalz verlinkt worden ist wird
dahin auch weiterhin für hinweise
geschaltet bleiben
werben sie dafür dass die leute uns
weiterhin welche gehen nachdem sich die
einleitung der ermittlungen immer weiter
abzeichnete ist das landeskriminalamt
rheinland pfalz gebeten worden im fall
der absehbaren verfahrenseinleitung die
polizeilichen ermittlungen zu führen
bereits heute konnten deswegen gestern
erwirkte durchsuchungsbeschlüsse
vollstreckt werden
durchsucht wurde der krisenstab des
landkreises ahrweiler um dort die
unterlagen zu den tagen 14 fünfzehnter
2021 und auch die in dieser zeit
verwendeten kommunikationsmittel
sicherzustellen
welche gründe haben nun zur einleitung
dieses verfahrens geführt
der zeitliche aufriss der ereignisse
entlang der ahr den wir aus den schon
erwähnten quellen vorgenommen haben hat
ergeben dass die zunächst bestehende
annahme einer sozusagen extrem schnell
entstandenen und extrem schnell durch
das aatal strömende flutwelle und
zutreffend war
vielmehr gehen wir mittlerweile davon
aus dass das hochwasser der arsch und um
etwa 17 uhr schuld erreicht hatte
das ist der ort der zu beginn der
berichterstattung geradezu zum sinnbild
für die folgen dieser
unwetterkatastrophe kalt geworden ist
dort war es bereits zu starken
sachschäden gekommen wenn es auch
glücklicher weise nicht zu schäden an
menschen gekommen ist sind sich hat das
hochwasser jedoch offenbar erst gegen 2
uhr 30 erreicht zwischen diesen beiden
zeitlichen polen liegen immerhin rund
neun stunden innerhalb derer sich nach
allen uns bekannt gewordenen parametern
die flut lage fortlaufend verschlechtert
hat der pegelanstieg solange er noch
funktionierte die pegel prognosen ließen
abgesehen von einer offenbar relativ
schnell korrigierten meldung wonach der
höchste pegel schon wieder falle keine
entspannung sondern im gegenteil eine
seite und auch sehr deutliche
verschlechterung der situation erwarten
der prognostizierte pegel von 6 meter
neunzig lag auch sehr deutlich über den
pegelstand des sogenannten
jahrhunderthochwasser von 2016 wo er
wohl bei etwa drei meter 75 gelegen
hatte
nicht zuletzt kam es auch entlang der aa
bereits zu erheblichen sach und später
auch zu personenschäden
dies wird auch aus sicht der
staatsanwaltschaft die auch von ihnen
bereits vielfach artikulierte frage auf
warum eine deutliche warnung vor diesen
gefahren die sich da abzeichnet an die
bevölkerung oder auch die
evakuierungsanordnung erst um 23 uhr 9
verfügt und dann per cut waren
möglicherweise auch bernina die angaben
dazu sind im moment noch widersprüchlich
bekannt gemacht worden sind
wenn ich das hier so vor trage dann
klingt das alles doch recht klar und
eindeutig das ist es aber nicht denn
noch fehlen uns viele viele
informationen
bisher ist uns zb noch nicht bekannt was
zum beispiel über das ausmaß der schäden
entlang der ahr zb über umstände die die
hier gezeichnete dramatik der situation
möglicherweise auch abgemeldet haben
der krisenstab wusste auch ist uns nicht
bekannt wie die im krisenstaat
eingegangenen informationen dort
bewertet worden sind oder wer im
einzelnen diese bewertungen vorgenommen
hat und aus welchen gründen er sie so
bewertet hat wie sie bewertet worden
sind und wir wissen auch nicht welche
informationen der krisenstab jeweils in
die fläche gegeben hat zb an die
feuerwehren oder auch an andere
rettungskräfte bekannt ist uns aus
vielen zuschriften und auch aus
einzelnen videos die sie vermutlich auch
kennen das feuerwehren entlang der aa
warnungen ausgesprochen haben
wir wissen aber zum beispiel noch nicht
ob dies das ergebnis von anordnungen
oder hinweisen des krisenstabes gewesen
ist oder worauf im einzelnen diese
warnungen zurückgehen
unklar ist uns bisher auch welche
tatsächlichen möglichkeiten zu welchen
zeitpunkten bestanden haben zu agieren
nachdem jedenfalls teile der
infrastruktur darunter wohl auch teile
der handynetze und telefonnetze auch das
stromnetz ausgefallen waren
wir wissen auf der anderen seite aber
schon dass jedenfalls ein teil der netze
auch noch relativ lange funktioniert hat
trotz aller dieser unsicherheiten sieht
die staatsanwaltschaft bereits jetzt
zureichende tatsächliche anhaltspunkte
und das ist eine formulierung die stammt
aus der strafprozessordnung die wird
gerne immer so ein anführungszeichen von
ihnen geschrieben als ein komisches
juristendeutsch es ist der terminus
technicus aus der sdp aber wir sehen
bereits jetzt zureichende tatsächliche
anhaltspunkte dafür dass warnungen
verspätet und möglicherweise
unzureichend war
und auch evakuierungen möglicherweise zu
spät und wiederum möglicherweise
unzureichend angeordnet waren
wäre das so würde das den vorwurf
fahrlässige unterlassens dieser
warnungen und der evakuierung also
richtiger warnungen und richtiger
evakuierungsanordnung begründen und
leider besteht auch der anfangsverdacht
dass durch entsprechende versäumnisse
menschen zu tode gekommen sind oder auch
verletzt worden sind
dazu an dieser stelle nur eines nach den
bisherigen erkenntnissen kam es nach 42
runden tod bewohnern einer wohngruppe in
einem haus der lebenshilfe in sind sich
die person die nachtwache in dem haus
hatte hatte eigenen angaben zufolge
offenbar noch eine wohngruppe in einer
in der nähe des haupthauses der
lebenshilfe in sind sich befindlichen
doppelhaushälfte in das haupthaus
evakuieren können beim evakuieren der
gruppe in der anderen doppelhaushälfte
wurde die nachtwache jedoch von dem sehr
schnell steigenden wasser offenbar
bereits eingeschlossen so dass sie sich
mitsamt der gruppe in diesem haus in das
zweite stockwerk retten musste weil auch
das erste stockwerk vom hochwasser
betroffen waren nach einiger zeit
die gruppe im erdgeschoss des
haupthauses wurde durch das mit
erheblicher wucht durch das gebäude
strömende wasser getötet dabei sind
zimmer wände eingerissen worden so stark
war der druck zumindest für diese
personen ist jedenfalls anzunehmen dass
sie bei einer früheren deutlicheren
warnung vor den gefahren und auf einem
bei einer früheren deutlichen
evakuierungsanordnung hätten gerettet
werden können
wenn ich diese toten besonders
hervorheben dann tue ich das nicht etwa
bei mir die anderen toten womöglich
weniger wichtig wären jedes menschen
leben ist kostbar und jedes
menschenleben was dort verloren gegangen
ist es eines zuviel für die anderen
toten werden wir allerdings noch
ermittlungen dazu führen müssen
ob und wie sie auf ihre angehörigen auf
frühere warnungen reagiert hätten und ob
überhaupt zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
rettungs und reaktionsmöglichkeiten
bestanden hätten
daher bitte ich um verständnis dass ich
auf die vielen anderen toten an dieser
stelle nicht weiter eingehen kann ich
weiß einfach zu wenig dazu der
anfangsverdacht für das eingeleitete
verfahren richtet sich derzeit gegen
zwei beschuldigte zum einen gegen den
landrat des landkreises ahrweiler und
ein weiteres mitglied des krisenstabs
die beschuldigten stellungen ergeben
sich im wesentlichen aus rechtlichen
erwägungen der katastrophenschutz ist in
rheinland pfalz wie wohl auch in den
meisten anderen bundesländern wenn nicht
in allen kommunale pflichtaufgabe
das heißt er obliegt den gemeinden und
auch den landkreisen bei
übergemeindlichen ereignissen
der landrat ist nach den einschlägigen
gesetzlichen bestimmungen der
einsatzleiter in einem katastrophenfall
ab der stufe 4 die der landkreis
ahrweiler hier um 17.40 am 14.7 2021
ausgerufen hatte als einsatzleiter hat
er nach dem gesetz die alleinige
entscheidungsgewalt während alle anderen
mitglieder im krisenstab seine behörden
usw
lediglich zu arbeiten aus diesen gründen
sehen wir den landrat als beschuldigten
an
allerdings hatten wir einen hinweis aus
der bevölkerung dass die einsatzleitung
die wir zu der zeit noch dachten
zumindest zeitweise von einer anderen
person im einsatzstab wahrgenommen
worden ist dass sich bei dieser person
nicht um eine politische verantwortung
tragenden menschen handelt bitte ich um
nachsicht dafür dass ich ihnen
angesichts der geltenden
unschuldsvermutung und nach den
einschlägigen medien rechtlichen
regelungen unseres landes weder den
namen noch die funktion dieser person
mitteilen werde
heute morgen haben wir bei der
kreisverwaltung ahrweiler durchsucht und
bei dieser durchsuchung hat der landrat
uns mitgeteilt dass er die gesamte
einsatzleitung in katastrophenfällen die
der landkreis zu bearbeiten hat generell
auf die von mir genannte person
delegiert hat und zwar schon 2000 also
seit das ist schon seit vielen jahren so
dass das so delegiert ist er selbst habe
sich weit überwiegend wird er während
der zeit in der sich diese katastrophe
abgespielt hat nicht in der
kreisverwaltung aufgehalten sondern sei
per handy unterrichtet worden
er sieht daher bei sich keine
strafrechtliche verantwortung für
mögliche einsatzfehler da das gesetz die
aufgaben und entscheidungsbefugnisse in
einem katastrophenfall wie hier sehr
eindeutig die call der kommunalen ebene
zuweist
und das ist auch sinnvoll denn das ist
die ebene die die gegebenheiten und
akteure vor ort in aller regel besser
kennen wird als andere ebenen besteht
auch kein anfangsverdacht gegen
staatliche akteure die im staatsaufbau
behalten oberhalb der kreisverwaltung
angesiedelt sind
auch wenn diese teilweise in bei uns
eingehenden strafanzeigen beschuldigt
werden
das geht bis hin zur bundeskanzlerin
das werden wir nun tun durch die
ermittlungen werden wir zum einen
versuchen den ablauf der katastrophe
möglichst detailliert und genau
nachzuzeichnen
wann hat es wo welche flutfolgen gegeben
wann sind wie welche teile der
infrastruktur ausgefallen das sind
fragen die sich in diesem zusammenhang
stellen werden und die wir versuchen
werden zu klären
einen weiteren wichtigen teil der
ermittlungen wird die frage bilden
welche genauen kenntnisse den im
krisenstab handelnden personen für den
katastrophenschutz zu welchen
zeitpunkten zur verfügung gestanden
haben und welche überlegungen und
schlussfolgerungen sie auf diese
informationen dann welche überlegungen
sie angestellt hat und welche
schlussfolgerungen sie daraus gestützt
haben es wird weiterhin auch darum gehen
zu erfahren wie diese schluss forderung
schlussfolgerungen in die fläche
kommuniziert worden sind dabei wird sich
auch die familie bereits angesprochene
frage stellen welche praktischen
möglichkeiten denn zu welchen
zeitpunkten überhaupt noch bestanden
warnungen und anordnungen umzusetzen
im rahmen der durchsuchung heute morgen
ist beispielsweise bekannt geworden dass
offenbar der auslöser für die feuerwehr
sirenen die es entlang der aa in jedem
ort geben soll nicht mehr ab einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt der nicht genau
benannt worden ist wegen stromausfalls
nicht mehr funktioniert hatte man konnte
diese lehnen also vom kreishaus aus
nicht mehr betätigen
auf der anderen seite ist aber auch
gesagt worden dass diese auslöser nur
eine feuerwehralarmierung ermöglichen
kann also das dreimal kurzer auf heulen
der sirenen keine warnungen der
bevölkerung
wichtig auch für vorwürfe der
unterlassenen hilfeleistung die
insbesondere in einem gesondert
geführten verfahren erhoben worden sind
wird auch die frage sein wie auf
hilferufe aus der bevölkerung reagiert
worden ist und auch da wird sich die
frage stellen welche
reaktionsmöglichkeiten denn überhaupt zu
welchen zeitpunkten und in welchen
gegenden noch zur verfügung gestanden
haben
ich habe diese ermittlungen jetzt nur
kurz angerissen und skizziert man könnte
darüber sehr sehr viel sagen aber nicht
weil wir uns ermittlungen natürlich auch
schützen wollen sie werden jedoch
nachvollziehen können dass diese
ermittlungen umfangreich sein werden und
sie werden sicherlich auch einige zeit
in anspruch nehmen müssen
mit schnellen ergebnissen ist nicht zu
rechnen
mir und allen an diesem verfahren
beteiligten ist dabei sehr bewusst dass
dies für die vom tod angehöriger durch
verletzungen oder durch den verlust
ihrer habe traumatisierten menschen
schlimm ist wenn das dauert warten
müssen auf einer aufklärung die man
braucht um das schreckliche erlebt und
das was man da zu lesen bekommt es
wirklich schrecklich überhaupt
verarbeiten zu können das ist belastend
und das ist in manchen fällen auch
grausam
ich kann es nicht anders sagen wenn sie
die
berichterstattung von opfern loveparade
breitscheidplatz oder so sehen das ist
furchtbar wenn so etwas lange dauert
angesichts der ereignisse
der kleine kindern ich wohl nicht
zuletzt im interesse auch der
geschädigten aber auch dem der
beschuldigten gründlichkeit vor
schnelligkeit gehen
gleichwohl werden wir uns sehr bemühen
unsere arbeit möglichst schnell zu
machen und auch möglichst roth abschied
einmal mit
der verben leiber technische probleme
bei der übertragung der pressekonferenz
da sind wir selbst nicht besonders
glücklich mit aber wir haben denke ich
das wichtigste gehört und das wollen wir
jetzt aufbereiten ich erzähle es nochmal
batterien aus dem zdf-studio andernfalls
ist heute bei uns zu gast bobby du warst
von anfang an mit beginn der
flutkatastrophe im aartal und hast da
auch für uns berichtet bei dieser
pressekonferenz geht es jetzt darum ich
fasse es noch mal kurz zusammen dass
gegen den landrat des kreises ahrweiler
ermittelt wird gegen jürgen köhler und
da stehen folgende vorwürfe im raum es
geht im prinzip um unterlassene
hilfeleistung und um die frage hat er zu
spät warnungen herausgegeben
vielleicht kannst du noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen was harald große der
leitende oberstaatsanwalt schafft da
heute bekannt gegeben ja also die
staatsanwaltschaft hat ja schon anfang
der woche gesagt sie prüft sie fängt
erst mal an zu prüfen ob es ein
ermittlungsverfahren geben könnte ob es
überhaupt einen anfangsverdacht gibt das
hat sich jetzt also abgezeichnet und
ende der woche ende dieser woche hat es
jetzt also noch einmal erhärtet es geht
also um diese zentrale frage hätten
menschenleben gerettet werden können es
war klar dass es dieses große unwetter
geben wird das tief benting über
deutschland der deutsche wetterdienst
und andere institutionen haben gewarnt
vor heftigen regenfällen vor
überschwemmungen
das ist also etwas was man wusste und an
diesem tag an dem es dann besonders
schlimm wurde an dem 14 juli hat sich
das dann abgezeichnet nach und nach hier
in rheinland pfalz ist es so dass das
landesumweltamt also das landesamt für
umwelt bei dem die hochwasserzentrale
angesiedelt ist die stände die
pegelstände von der aa immer wieder
zyklisch durchgibt und ab bestimmten
zeitpunkten greifen dann mechanismen
dann treten warnstufe nein
und da ist halt eben die große frage
hätte man auf diese warnungen anders
früher reagieren müssen also wenn man
sich das anschaut die pegelstände hat
uns das landesamt für umwelt auch
geschickt von diesem 14
von der ada hat man gesehen
schon um 18 uhr 25 da stand die aber
relativ hoch also die genauen umstände
wird jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert das
alles nachzulesen aber im grunde ist es
so die a stieg und stieg dann gab es
eine kurze absenkung und danach stieg
sie exorbitant weiter und hatte da
eigentlich schon die aller höchste
warnstufe eigentliche warnstufe hoch 2
also die aller höchste warnstufe hoch 2
überschritten und das war im grunde
schon um acht uhr abends hat sich das
abgezeichnet hat sich dann immer weiter
verschärft die lage der katastrophenfall
im kreis ahrweiler wurde allerdings erst
das haben wir gerade in der
pressekonferenz gehört
um 23 uhr 9 ausgerufen und jetzt ist
eben die frage das was der leitende
staatsanwalt gerade sehr deutlich gesagt
hat er ist keine plötzliche flutwelle
gewesen es ging nicht darum dass diese
flutwelle kam und innerhalb weniger
minuten die herunter gespühlt ist und
alle orte von denen wir jetzt so oft
gehört haben
dernau altena mai schoss bad neuenahr
ahrweiler in wenigen minuten überflutet
hat sondern diese welle ist gewandert
über mehrere stunden und die zentrale
frage ist hätte man zu einem früheren
zeitpunkt den katastrophenfall ausrufen
müssen orte die weiter hinter gelagert
sind frühzeitig intensiver warnen können
und damit menschenleben retten können
genau der konkrete anfangsverdacht
es wird ermittelt wegen fahrlässiger
tötung und fahrlässiger körperverletzung
durch unterlassen wir wollen das doch
mal ein bisschen zusammen fassen weil
der ton irgendwie an der pressekonferenz
immer wieder ausgefallen ist
es wird gegen landrat pföhler ermittelt
es wird aber auch noch gegen eine
weitere person ermittelt vielleicht
kannst du da noch mal was zu erklären ja
das ist glaube ich gerade auch noch mal
sehr gut deutlich geworden der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt hast das ja sehr klar
gesagt es gab ja viele vorwürfe auch
sehr breit gestreut nicht nur gegen die
kommunale ebene sondern das haben wir in
der vergangenheit auch immer wieder
mitbekommen da wurde das die rheinland
pfälzische landesregierung auch
verantwortlich gemacht und die frage
aufgeworfen warum wurde da auf der ebene
nicht mehr gemacht gab es da versäumt es
sind offensichtlich gab es vorwürfe
die an die staatsanwaltschaft
herangetragen worden sind die bis zur
bundeskanzlerin ging der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt hat ja gerade sehr
deutlich gemacht in diesem fall hier in
rheinland pfalz ist der
katastrophenschutz eine kommunale
pflichtaufgabe
dementsprechend steht der landrat in der
pflicht also ist es seine zentrale
aufgabe ab einer bestimmten warnstufe
die einsatzleitung zu übernehmen und
jetzt ist eben die frage die sich auch
aus der pressekonferenz ergeben hat ob
der landrat tatsächlich das sagen hatte
er hat ja offensichtlich der
staatsanwaltschaft gegenüber schon
geäußert er hätte diese aufgabe diese
sehr wichtige aufgabe delegiert das
offensichtlich dass sheen jetzt aber
auch keinem bewusst gewesen zu sein
das ist eine info die jetzt neu dazu
kommt also anscheinend hatte die
staatsanwaltschaft die schon vorher
und da ist natürlich so die frage die
man jetzt im nachgang klären muss ich
glaube das können wir zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt juristisch nicht bewerten
inwieweit man so eine kernaufgabe die ja
wirklich ich nenne es jetzt mal ganz
platt chefsache ist einfach eine unebene
darunter geben kann
also das heißt die rolle des landrates
muss geklärt werden und offensichtlich
diese zweite person um die es geht die
soll jetzt noch nicht klarer benannt
werden weil sie offensichtlich nicht die
gleiche öffentlichkeit genießt wie der
landrat und so aufgrund der
unschuldsvermutung jetzt auch medial
nicht allzu sehr in den fokus gestellt
werden soll
und hallo sagt eben in der
pressekonferenz gesagt dass der landrat
auch gar nicht selbst vor ort war
sondern sich bei handy hat informieren
und auf dem laufenden halten lassen dass
wir doch noch einen punkt sein jetzt zu
klären sein wird
ja mit sicherheit also auf der einen
seite ist natürlich die frage die
rechtliche frage ist das legitim
also das was wir gerade angesprochen
haben kann man die aufgabe als landrat
diese kernaufgabe einfach so delegieren
und dann ist es sicher auch eine ja ich
nenne es jetzt mal moralische frage bei
einer lage die sich so abzeichnet bei
der schon deutlich war das sie schlimm
wird viele sagen auch dass die so
schlimm bild konnte man nicht sehen aber
bei der man schon gemerkt hat das ist
eine ernste angelegenheit hätte der
landrat vielleicht nicht doch in der
kreisverwaltung in der einsatzzentrale
sein sollen auch wenn er vielleicht ein
teil der aufgabe schon delegiert hat das
ist dann sicher eher so die moralische
ebene auch die mustern im nachgang noch
bewertet
ganz unabhängig von der frage ob er das
überhaupt durfte oder nicht
absolut wir wollen bei allem was jetzt
im raum steht bei allen vorwürfen
natürlich auch noch mal betonen dass das
ist nun mal so es gilt die
unschuldsvermutung und jetzt wird erst
mal ermittelt wegen eines
anfangsverdachts landrat müller hat die
vorwürfe schon im vor ein paar tagen
zurückgewiesen
dazu kann ich mal ein zitat vorlesen das
können wir vielleicht kurz zeigen ja
weil gegenseitige schuldzuweisungen sind
völlig deplatziert geschmacklos und
verkennen den ernst der lage zurzeit
kann niemand im bund im land oder im
kreis seriös die fragen nach
verantwortlichkeiten beantworten
er hat noch weiter gesagt dies müsse
später sehr sorgfältig aufgearbeitet
werden damit man eben für künftige
großschadenslagen gewappnet ist
das hat er jetzt vor der pressekonferenz
gesagt zu diesen ganzen vorwürfen hat er
sich noch nicht öffentlich geäußert aber
das zeigt mir auch dass da da da war
schon was im laufen also der der druck
auf landrat pföhler in den letzten teil
noch mal massiv gestiegen ja ganz massiv
tatsächlich hat sich das am vergangenen
wochenende schon abgezeichnet
da haben sich diese vorwürfe dann auch
nochmal erhärtet und es gab auch schon
davor die ein oder andere spitze könnte
man sagen vom rheinland-pfälzischen
innenminister roger lewentz der auch in
einem interview ja so ein stück weit
darauf hingewiesen hat so nach dem motto
es ist also was immer da passiert ist
fragen sie das den landrat nicht mich ja
da hat man schon auch gemerkt das war so
ein vorsichtiges sich wehren gegen
mögliche vorwürfe oder ganz klares
zuweisen von verantwortung was wir wie
wir jetzt gelernt haben auch in dem fall
völlig berechtigt war
in dem fall ging es dann aber auch so
weit dass die bei der pressekonferenz
ließ dann mal danach gab mit dem landrat
mit dem innenminister da war es dann
schon wieder ein bisschen ruhiger also
nach diesen ersten äußerungen auch vom
innenminister hat sich das nicht weiter
hochgeschaukelt da hat man ein bisschen
das gefühl dass alle parteien so ein
bisschen darauf achten diese sehr
schwierige situation
vielen toten mit vielen verletzten mit
ganz vielen menschen die traumatisiert
sind und ja zuhause verloren haben
das in keiner weise irgendwie so
ausgelegt werden könnte dass eine partei
das vielleicht jetzt im rahmen des
wahlkampfs ausschlachtet insofern hatte
ich da so den eindruck bei dieser
pressekonferenz bei der ich auch selber
waren bad neuenahr ahrweiler dass das so
eine art ja agreement ist dass wir uns
jetzt hier nicht gegenseitig oder dass
sich die politiker da nicht gegenseitig
massiven schuldzuweisungen machen in dem
fall scheint es ja auch so zu sein man
hat das den institutionen überlassen die
dafür zuständig sind in dem fall jetzt
der strafverfolgung und die hat er jetzt
auch ihre arbeit aufgenommen
ich möchte mal einen kommentar von hans
jürgen kühl auf facebook vorlesen der
schreibt für mich kommen die
schuldzuweisungen viel zu früh mit
absicht hat das doch irgend jemand
gemacht das sollte man nach den
aufräumarbeiten
sollte das dann erst gemacht werden
jetzt sind andere sachen wichtiger als
schuldzuweisung
damit spricht er wahrscheinlich aus der
seele vieler betroffener die natürlich
wollen dass das juristisch aufgearbeitet
wird aber die jetzt hat täglich ganz
andere sorgen haben
ja da spricht der user tatsächlich einen
ganz reellen punkt an und ich bin
gestern noch unterwegs gewesen
da waren wir in dernau und du hast es ja
auch gerade gesagt wir liegen jetzt drei
wochen ungefähr nach dieser
flutkatastrophe und trotzdem ist dieses
bild menschen die aufräumen die immer
noch versuchen einfach so minimum an
ordnung zu schaffen das vorherrschende
bild immer noch riesige müllberge die
abtransportiert werden müssen und von
normalität ist diese region wirklich
ganz ganz stark entfernt und da liegt
der schluss natürlich nahe zu sagen
haben die menschen jetzt nicht gerade
andere sorgen
im grund dass das stimmt also gerade
funktionieren die menschen und versuchen
immer noch mit den folgen der
katastrophe klar zu kommen
was uns aber auch immer wieder gesagt
wurde auch von ärztinnen und ärzten
seelsorgern
immer wieder kommt jetzt auch so der
punkt bei den menschen das dass sie ins
verarbeiten kommen so und nach und nach
nimmt dieses arbeiten also dies
körperliche arbeiten ab sie kommen zur
ruhe und realisieren eigentlich was
passiert ist das ist ein sehr sensibler
moment und natürlich stellt sich da auch
die frage kommen die leute auf die idee
nach der schule zu fragen wer ist
eigentlich verantwortlich dafür
dass ich hier mein zuhause verloren habe
wäre es vielleicht verantwortlich dafür
dass meinen dass meine nachbarn in der
flut gestorben sind solche geschichten
haben wir auch gehört und deswegen
glaube ich ist es ganz wichtig dass die
staatsanwaltschaft sich jetzt frühzeitig
darum gekümmert hat und auch frühzeitig
signalisieren kann das auch dieser frage
nachgegangen wird bevor sich da
vielleicht eine wut aufbaut entlädt
fragen gestellt werden warum wird nicht
ermittelt die man jetzt natürlich sehr
gut entgegenwirken kann und sagen kann
das ist eine sehr ernste angelegenheit
der leitende oberstaatsanwalt kruse hat
sich ja gerade auch sehr betroffen
gezeigt und diese angelegenheit wird
jetzt nachgegangen
wobei er ja auch ganz klar gesagt hat
und das kann man auch als fazit ziehen
als dieser pressekonferenz eben das
wahnsinnig viele fragen offen sind und
dass es wirklich sehr sehr lange dauern
wird diese zu beantworten und das auch
nicht klar ist aber alle fragen
beantwortet werden können am ende ist
alles ja dazu muss man ja auch immer
noch mal sagen es sind jetzt
ermittlungen
es ist noch keine anklage erhoben worden
das muss man juristisch natürlich auch
ganz klar trennen und dieses diese
schwierigkeit die der staatsanwalt da
beschrieben hat das ist auch etwas was
uns immer wieder begegnet ist in den
vergangenen wochen kolleginnen kollegen
von mir die unterwegs waren und die wir
die menschen gefragt haben so wie ist
das denn eigentlich gewesen in dieser
nacht was haben sie eigentlich erlebt
wann wurden sie gewarnt
und da ist es ganz schwer ein
einheitliches bild zu zeichnen erstens
weil wir halt über ganz viele
unterschiedliche orte entlang der ahr
sprechen weil die menschen ganz
unterschiedlich sich vorbereitet haben
auf dieses hoch also auf diese auf diese
regenfälle erst mal nur die einen sagen
ja uns war klar dass es regnet aber dass
es so doll wird das wussten wir nicht
viele hatten zum beispiel weder card
waren noch nina auf dem handy das
natürlich dann auch so die frage
inwieweit inwieweit deren aussagen
einfließen können in diese ermittlungen
und viele können sich schlichtweg auch
nicht mehr daran erinnern wann was
passiert ist weil als dann das wasser
kam hatte glaube ich keiner mehr zeit
auf die uhr zu schauen also das sind
wirklich drastische schilderungen um die
es geht menschen die noch versucht als
die hat die die situation gar nicht
erfasst haben die in den keller gegangen
sind gedacht haben wir können jetzt noch
irgendetwas retten dann merken plötzlich
dass das wasser die tür zu drückt sich
dann durch die tür noch nach oben
haben weil sie sonst im keller
wahrscheinlich ertrunken wären die haben
tatsächlich dann nicht mehr auf die
zeitlichen abläufe geguckt und hatten
auch schlichtweg danach viele
möglichkeiten nicht mehr weil ja
telekommunikation handys ähnliches
ausgefallen sind da sind ganz viele
möglichkeiten der zeitlichen
nachverfolgung weggefallen das erschwert
die ermittlungen jetzt da sagt einer die
wahlen stehen vor der tür da wollen die
parteien ein opfer um von ihrer eigenen
verfehlten politik abzulenken und ein
anderer magic es schreibt erinnert mich
an die loveparade keiner hat schuld und
jeder schiebt den anderen den schwarzen
peter zu das sagte der leitende
oberstaatsanwalt ja eben auch der hat
die loveparade-katastrophe und den
anschlag vom breitscheidplatz
angesprochen wie schwierig dann in so
einer situation ermittlungen werden und
wie man so liest in den sozialen medien
haben einige rehe auch wenig hoffnung
dass das überhaupt sauber aufgearbeitet
werden kann
ja ich glaube die ganze flutkatastrophe
wird auf allen ebenen sehr sehr sehr
viel zeit brauchen
das sind nicht nur die
wiederaufbauarbeiten von den man
eigentlich überhaupt nicht absehen kann
wie lange sie brauchen werden also das
ausmaß der zerstörung jedes mal wenn wir
dort in den orten unterwegs sind fragen
wir uns also alle kolleginnen und
kollegen wie lange soll das eigentlich
dauernd ist das jahr halbwegs wieder
bewohnbar ist gas wasser strom fehlt ja
an einigen stellen immer noch also wir
haben diese baulichen stehen wir haben
die traumatisierten menschen das wird
auch sehr sehr lange dauern bis man die
überhaupt erst mal alle identifiziert
hat wer braucht eigentlich hilfe und wer
braucht welche hilfe und dass man denen
helfen kann das ist ein sehr langer
prozess das sind nicht wochen das nicht
monate das sind jahre um die es da geht
und da liegt es natürlich auch nahe dass
diese ermittlungen sehr sehr lange
dauern werden der staatsanwalt hat ja
gerade auch gesagt das ist ein
e-mail-postfach eingerichtet worden
ich glaube dass die zahl waren es jetzt
50 bis 60 hinweise sind bisher aus der
bevölkerung eingegangen und er hofft
auch noch auf mehr
und da wird wahrscheinlich jetzt dadurch
dass die ermittlungen aufgenommen worden
sind auch noch mehr kommen das alles
auszuwerten
das braucht zeit galt ja auch gerade
wieder dieser spruch den die behörden
relativ oft sagen ja gründlichkeit vor
schnelligkeit
ob das natürlich den leuten dann hilft
im aartal das ist dann lange dauert ist
zu bezweifeln dass da wird
wahrscheinlich irgendwann der frust
kommen und tatsächlich muss man ja auch
sagen noch ist nicht klar ob es eine
anklage geben wird noch es nicht klar
wenn es eine anklage geben wird wird das
zu einer verurteilung kommen da gibt es
also ganz ganz viele fragezeichen werfen
da sind ja in den letzten tagen die rufe
nach einem sonderbeauftragten oder eine
sonderbeauftragten immer lauter geworden
und malu dreyer die ministerpräsidentin
von rheinland pfalz hat heute auch eine
pressekonferenz gegeben zusammen mit dem
innenminister lewentz und da wollen wir
ganz kurz auch mal reinschauen
ich wollte sie informieren auch darüber
dass wir sehr intensiv mit dem bund
moment den wiederaufbau vor diskutieren
entwickeln mal am 10 august in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ja der
beschluss gefasst werden soll und es
zeichnet sich auch ab
das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch noch im
august einen deutschen bundestag geben
wird und ein bundesrat das ganze dann
letztendlich auch in einem gesetz zu
verabschieden so dass wir dann
handlungsfähig sind was das thema
wiederaufbau betrifft denkst du dass
diese maßnahmen ausreichen werden ist
das schon ein großer schritt oder ich
glaube dieser große begriff wiederaufbau
von der muss jetzt mit inhalt gefüllt
werden was bedeutet dass das ist so das
was sich die leute gerade fragen
es geht es stehen summen im raum also
uns wurde gestern noch gesagt es geht um
10 milliarden investitionsvolumen
alleine um da halbwegs wieder auf die
beine zu kommen aber die frage was ist
das hat man damit jetzt nur straßen
wieder hergestellt strom gelegt
wasseranschlüsse und vielleicht die
groben schäden dann beseitigt es geht
aber auch um ganz andere fragen wenn wir
an style denken das ist eine touristisch
geprägte region viele winzer viele
urlauber
das ist ein ganz entscheidender
wirtschaftsfaktor gewesen und die
touristen die kommen jetzt natürlich
nicht die können jetzt erst mal nicht
kommen weil viele orte zerstört sind und
die orte die vielleicht nicht zerstört
sind werden jetzt nicht angefahren weil
die leute verunsichert sind
das ist eine ganz zentrale frage dass
sich die menschen auch dort vor ort
gefragt haben immer wieder vor uns dass
sie sagen wie kriegt man das hin so
schnell wie möglich dieser region eine
struktur zu geben dass sie sich selber
helfen kann mit den einnahmen die sie
auch vorher hatte das sehe ich als eine
ganz ganz große aufgabe an
das muss koordiniert werden dass diese
region wieder das schafft leute
anzuziehen einnahmen zu generieren damit
den aufbau auch selber voranzutreiben
wie da so ein wiederaufbau von helfen
kann das ist glaube ich eine der ganz
zentralen fragen wie ich eben sagte das
muss mit inhalt gefüllt werden und da
braucht es wirklich das sagen auch immer
wieder die menschen ganz ganz großer
anstrengungen übergeordneter natur das
kann man lokal gar nicht selber stemmen
da muss es eine draufsicht geben einen
masterplan der der region wieder auf die
beine hilft
drei monaten kontakt zu berichten
ja also hessen kommen an ist wir haben
auch schon darüber berichtet also wo die
spendengelder hingehen da das gibt es
tatsächlich alles aber bei diesem ausmaß
der zerstörung muss man auch ganz klar
sagen das ist noch ein sehr weiter weg
wir haben jetzt gestern ich sagte in
dernau gedreht in dernau ist es so da
hat uns der ortsbürgermeister erzählt
also fließend wasser geht so langsam
strom geht so langsam was aber an ganz
vielen orten noch fehlt das gas und wenn
wir in kalender gucken so langsam kommt
der herbst ist wird kalt und dann gibt
es noch nicht so richtig die perspektive
ob das tatsächlich rechtzeitig klappt
haben alle häuser wieder eine heizung
viele häuser hatten auch öltanks die
haben sich dann vermischt mit dem
schlamm und mit dem dreck und viele
hausbewohner sagen oder hausbesitzer
sagen mir kommt hier keine öltank mehr
rein
womit soll man die häuser dann beheizen
im winter also das heißt dass das sind
große fragen ja hilfe kommt an
wir haben gestern auch gesprochen mit
dachdeckern die haben sich in einer
großen initiative dort gesammelt und
haben gesagt so wir gucken mal wo
überhaupt also wohl noch im dach drauf
ist dass man reparieren muss viele
dächer haben keine regenrinnen mehr
dadurch läuft das wasser auch noch mal
wenn es dann regnet unkontrolliert ins
das wird also schon gemacht und einen
dachdecker hat mir dann erzählt er hätte
er hätte auch die hoffen dass vielleicht
sanitär betriebe sagen sie machen eine
ähnliche aktion ja und sorgen dann dafür
dass sie in einer großen aktion sich
sammeln in die orte gehen dafür sorgen
das wasser wieder fließen kann
dass heizungen wieder angeschlossen
werden und ähnliches also da braucht es
halt eben die unterstützung von
fachleuten aber natürlich auch eine
steuerung absolut und dazu muss man auch
sagen ohne die vielen freiwilligen
helferinnen und helfer würde das
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht zu schnell
gehen sondern noch länger dauern
damit wollen wir es für heute belassen
vielen dank für deinen schilderung und
deine eindrücke du wirst uns auch weiter
auf dem laufenden halten
und ich kann vielleicht noch mal kurz
hinterher schieben das problem bei der
übertragung der pressekonferenz lag an
einem kabel problem war so was tut uns
leid
auf jeden fall können wir euch
versprechen dass wir die situation der
menschen in den flutgebieten auf jeden
fall weiter im auge behalten werden und
auch weiter darüber berichten werden für
st heute danke fürs zuschauen und melden
uns bald wieder ein schönes wochenende
tschüss